nous partons en stage dès le 6 juin nous
avons fait un don qu'on appelle comme
vous le disiez en anglais au public
aujourd'hui vont les choses ne bougent
pas beaucoup puisque à l'heure où je
vous parle nous avons 29 contributeurs
qu'une somme de 1700 euros et vous devez
récolter on doit récolter entre 100 et
180 mille euros en fonction des derniers
ajustements budgétaires que nous avons
fait cette semaine
alors de deux choses l'une on peut se
dire que bon le football n'intéresse pas
le plus grand nombre ou alors que nous
avons mal communiqué moi je pensais
qu'aujourd'hui que nous avons mais quand
vous allez vous fîtes est justement de
cette finale pour finir en cours des
événements à venir pour encore lancé
sensibiliser la population à cet appel
aux dons mais déjà on va commencer pas
profiter de l'occasion que vous nous
offrez pour demander au public
martiniquais qui aiment le football qui
aiment la martinique donc de soutenir la
sélection d'articles et matinaux en
faisant une souscription sur la
plateforme kiss kiss bang bang voilà
c'est une plateforme numérique ou alors
tout simplement parce qu'il n'ya leur
qui n'aiment pas les mets le nez de
vania la devenir la ligue alors monté
rapidement si jamais on n'arrive pas à
atteindre cette somme est ce que du coup
ça veut dire que la partie ne
participait pas à la gaule qu'un
m'écouter nous sommes déjà engagés dans
la compétition donc une dépression comme
il n'ya lieu pas aujourd'hui les billets
sont pris l'hébergement est assuré par
la concacaf
voilà et puis nous avons sur fond de
change suivant sur un à côté de cela
donc non on participe on participe à
ceci étant nous devrons assumer le coût
financier de cette opération
mais nous ne doutons pas aujourd'hui de
la motivation et de démence mans et à
votre boutique tous les partenaires pour
que les matinaux puisse représenter
dignement lamartine